I'm Paul Farley and I'm a Weeblos leader with PAC 525 in Peach Tree Corners, Georgia.
This edition of Scout Master Podcast is sponsored by Backers Like Us.
And now the old Scout Master.
We were at the climbing tower at camp and one of my fellow scouters kind of knew to the
game. right,
He was a little nervous and he looks at me and he says, wow, how many times do
the scouts fall off of that tower?
And I said usually once is enough.
Hey, this is podcast number 298..
Hey,
Hey, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag.
Let's see
Ed Bruce is the Scout Master, Troop 38 in North Falmouth, Massachusetts,
And Ed wrote in to say your blog and podcast has been very helpful. but I really appreciate
the personal attention you've given me on several occasions over the past couple
of years.
Your advice has always been spot on and you've made me a kinder, gentler Scout Master
And I'm sure my scouts would be grateful to you for that.
Well, Ed,
I'm sure I will have some small part in making you kinder and gentler.
My scouts would probably be amazed that I was able to help anybody be kinder and gentler.
but you know, there you go, oh well,
Also in the mailbag we heard from Alan Green before. I read that though: hey, it's 2016..
And we're back after a holiday break.
We played three weeks of Encore presentations, and I mentioned that because Alan refers
to podcast number 297..
He says: do you have any plans to expand on the idea of one aim, one method you discussed
in podcast 297?
Maybe you could do an essay or something on it.
I would pass that kind of thing out to everyone I know in scouting because I think it's
right on.
Thank you.
Well, thanks, Alan,
And you know what
I'm happy to do that.
I don't know that I want to expand on it too much, because you know like the
whole idea was getting a one sentence job description for Scouters.
And if you haven't listened to that, go back to a podcast 297 and you can listen
to it.
And in the post that contains this podcast, I'll have a link to a brief overview
of exactly what I said there.
And if, like Alan, you think it'd be useful to print that out and share it,
Well, there you go,
Like most Scouters, after a few years. right, you've been to training
and you've read stuff. you've got probably a bookshelf full of stuff right,
Or a filing cabinet drawer, at least one, just packed with papers and things
like that,
And I think that's fine.
I think those resources are probably pretty valuable,
But I'm a little contrarian when it comes to paper,
And so I'm always interested in how little paper can we get away with.
So, Alan, the the write up that I did is one side of one sheet of eight
and a half by 11 paper
And I'm very proud of myself. if you couldn't tell,
There it is,
That's the source. that'll be in the post that contains this podcast
And I hope you all find it useful.
Hey, before the holidays we had a couple of chat sessions I wanted to catch up on.
We have live chat over at ScoutmasterCGcom, usually Tuesday and Wednesday mornings.
Watch the Facebook feed, watch the Twitter feed and I'll announce when I'm
going to be there live,
And a lot of folks sign in and we have a nice chat.
Sometimes it's about important, weighty matters and sometimes it's about the weather.
You know, just before the holidays Shane Adams checked into the chat and he's an
assistant Scoutmaster, who soon to be a Scoutmaster, probably already is, because
he said it was going to be at the turn of the year for Troop 99 in Yorba, Linda,
California.
Peter Belize checked in.
He's from New York and he's a 24 year old Eagle Scout who turned Scoutmaster.
And Peter, you got to know I was a very young Scoutmaster over 30 years ago
because I took over as Scoutmaster at the same age of 24..
Avery Moore checked in and he's a Scoutmaster for Troop 11 in Rocky Mountain,
North Carolina.
So, like I said, keep an eye on the Facebook feed and the Twitter feed.
Usually Tuesday and Wednesday mornings we'll have a few hours where you can
come over to ScoutmasterCGcom, sign in for a live chat
And, hey, we'd love to hear from you
Now. I hear from a lot of folks every week and it's very heartening to know
I'm able to lend them a hand.
And what I ask for in return that, if you're finding what we do here useful,
that you support the podcast by becoming a ScoutmasterCGcom backer.
It's pretty easy to do:
Just go to ScoutmasterCGcom, click the support link at the top of the page.
You're going to find a number of options on making a voluntary, one-time
kind of subscription payment to help me keep things up and running.
And I want to take a moment to personally thank Michael Dormer,
Greg Leslie, Roy Hollis and Greg Barnett, who've become backers since our last podcast.
Thank you very much.
And I'll take the time to tell you too that this is podcast number 298..
So that means in two weeks, podcast 300 is coming up
And I've got a couple of projects, a couple of things to announce during
podcast 300 because, hey, that's going to be six years since we started
the podcast and obviously, the 300th edition and it's the new year.
So, hey, it's a good time for new initiatives and new things happening at
ScoutmasterCGcom.
Make sure to tune in and we'll tell you all about them
In this week's podcast. while we're coming off the holidays,
we're going to take it easy and answer a few email questions,
And that takes up the remainder of this week's podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
He's my favorite all-time boy scout.
You're my favorite all-time boy scout.
You were always on the beat boy, beat boy.
Yeah, you were always on the beat boy, beat boy.
I'll hang it in the sweet boy, sweet boy.
We re-dancing to the beat boy, beat boy.
Yeah, you're my favorite all-time boy scout.
You're my favorite all-time boy scout.
He's my favorite all-time boy scout.
Write me a letter. send it by name
Email. that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
This question comes from Scott Pulaski, who is with Troop 778 in Wood River, Illinois,
And Scott says: thanks as always, for the awesome podcast.
That and the so far, so good book that you wrote have been a great help
As I've worked at getting our Troop to be youth-led.
I was actually made Scoutmaster of the Troop I grew up in at the first of the year
And I was looking for a meaningful and memorable first Scoutmasters minute.
I looked at a few sources but nothing really appealed to me.
Do you have any suggestions for what I should do for my first Scoutmasters minute?
Well, Scott, I'm always happy to hear the podcast is helping folks
And thank you so much for your kind words
And congratulations on being a new Scoutmaster too.
If I asked you to tell me why you wanted to be a Scoutmaster
and how you wanted to help your Scouts, what would you reply-
And, by the way, you only have two minutes to tell me.
I mean literally 120 seconds maximum.
Whatever that answer would be,
Scott, I think that's going to be your most meaningful and memorable Scoutmasters minute,
Because the most meaningful and memorable ones aren't ones that you know
we got out of a book somewhere or you got off my website.
No, it's the ones where you speak from your heart about things that really matter to you.
Now, if you're like me and you can talk the horns off a billy goat
or the feet off of a Dutch oven,
well, that means you're probably going to benefit from writing those ideas down
and practicing them a little bit
So you get it down to a point where you're not boring your Scouts to death right,
120 seconds is pretty bearable for most Scouts,
especially, like I said, if you're talking out from the heart, right to them.
I think that'll be a pretty memorable one.
What do you think, Scott?
The next email comes from James Eisenwein from Troop 104.
And he said, now that the year has turned in, 2016 is here.
can you repost your information about the change in rank requirements?
I'm specifically looking to answer the question
into what Scouts are allowed to work on with their current handbooks
and when they need to get a new Scout handbook.
Ah well, James, that's a great question,
And what I did is I took the time to set up an infographic
about when you have to apply the new rank requirements,
And so check that out at scoutmastercgcom.
I'll link to it in our podcast notes.
And as to the question: do Scouts have to get a new handbook
in order to have the new requirements signed off?
The answer is no,
And that comes directly from the BSA.
Specifically quote: a Scout may continue to use his existing handbook
as a reference and a resource.
However, he should also have a list of the new requirements
for the purpose of sign-offs,
And that list is available as a PDF that you can print out.
You can put it right in the handbook from the BSA
And I will have a link to that in the podcast notes too.
And so Scouts don't have to run out and get a new handbook.
You don't have to wait for the new handbook
to apply the new requirements.
And I'll say the last little bit of information here is-
and it's going to be a lot clearer
if you'll look at the infographic that I made-
Any Scout who joins after January 1, 2016
begins using the new requirements right away.
Scouts who were registered before December 31, 2015
use the old requirements until they reach first class,
after which they begin using the new requirements.
Or, if they have already passed first class,
they can complete the rank that they're working on
with the old requirements,
Then they must move on to the new requirements
And if you have a Scout who was registered in 2015
who doesn't reach first class by the end of 2016,,
in 2017, everybody uses the new requirements.
It's really not as complicated as it sounds.
Like I said, the infographic will help you out,
so check that out in the podcast notes.
And thanks for asking the question, James.
And this next email is from Tony Hooker,
who is a Venturing Advisor with Crew 222
in Concord, North Carolina.
And Tony wrote in to say
I listened to the One Aim, One Method podcast
And if you were listening earlier,
that was podcast number 297..
And Tony went on to say:
I'm involved as a dead leader for the pack
and I'm an assistant scout master for a troop
and an advisor for a crew.
I really emphatically agree with your importance
of the patrol method for Boy Scouts
And I also understand it within the Cub Scout den,
as you said, at an age appropriate level,
But I'm a little confused about how to apply it in Venturing.
I can understand how a group dynamics can be similar
to that within a patrol for most crews,
But there's really no patrol equivalent in Venturing
in a Venturing Crew with a large number of members.
I'm an advisor for a new crew
and I'm struggling to understand how aspects of the patrol method
can be integrated into that program.
Our crew focuses on STEM activities
and we have about 20 members.
What are some ways we can integrate the patrol method
into a larger crew or into a crew
that is less focused on camping and outdoor activities?
There's really no form of permanent small groups
within a crew, so I'm welcoming any advice you can give.
Well, Tony, I think it's pretty easy
to have the patrol method active in a Venturing Crew.
You just kind of make up small groups
and there's no reason that these need to be permanent small groups.
They can be formed around whatever activity you're pursuing.
I mean, working in the STEM NOVA environment as an emphasis
is one thing, but I've got to say you know,
I know it's going to be debatable,
but it's not really scouting.
STEM NOVA is not scouting.
Scouting is outdoors, camping and adventure.
It's important to achieving our aims
And I understand that a crew might be interested
in STEM NOVA stuff and if that's what you want to do,
that's what you want to do
And you can have some aspects of the patrol method active in that.
But, like I said, scouting focuses on adventure in the outdoors-
camping and trekking and that sort of thing. for a reason
That's our field of play, That's what we do.
Those are activities where the patrol method flourishes.
I understand the interest in the value of STEM NOVA stuff,
but things like that and team sports and debate
and music and theatricals are also a valuable thing,
And making STEM NOVA an emphasis for a Venture Crew
is kind of like having the debate team play handball in my mind.
So I guess I would have to question whether or not
that was a really good place to put your emphasis.
And in a lot of ways this question kind of bounces back to you.
Tell me what the benefits of the patrol method are specifically,
Have some understanding of those benefits
and you'll perhaps how to see to put them into action
in the activities that your crew is doing.
If you have a question or a comment or you need some answers,
you can get in touch with me, just like these folks did.
It's easy to do and I'm going to tell you how to do that in just a moment.
Thank you so much for listening to this 298th edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast.
You can read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can subscribe to receive updates to the blog by email.
Hey, we're all over social media.
You can join 11,000 folks who like Scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
We have 1,300 tweeters over on Twitter.
You can pin the Pultrudinous pictures proffered publicly
with 2,300 other prolific pinners on Pinterest.
You can watch us at ScoutmasterCG on YouTube.
but listen, if you can't face Facebook,
if Twitter makes you better, if you've no interest in Pinterest
and you don't put the? U in YouTube, that's alright, Bunky,
Just zoom into the late 90s and fire off an email.
You can email me, ClarkGreen,
your comments and questions at clark at scoutmastercgcom-
C-L-A-R-K-E-A-T,
ScoutmasterCGcom.
And if none of those options appeal to you,
I'll tell you what. next time you're out camping,
gather your fellow scouters around a magic mirror
and repeat ScoutmasterCG three times in unison
and I will magically appear to answer your questions.
By now, it should be abundantly clear
that the Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of anyone in particular,
including the Boy Scouts from America,
and they are not endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts from America
or any other scouting organization for that matter.
No, it is simply I.
I have access to a microphone and to the internet
and I do my best to try and lend a hand to Scouters
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun, here is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Pal. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why, thank you, sir.
Until next time, everyone.